i realized that if latin america wants
to develop
entrepreneurial innovative projects in
technology
we should join the venture capital
world
[Music]
lisandro brill thank you so much for
joining me on the show i really really
appreciate it
thank you pleasure it's so great to have
you i'm so excited to learn as much as i
can over these next 20 minutes about
your
your you know so so fascinating life
as a journalist television and then and
then going on to venture capital you've
made some incredible investments
you know an expert on latin america
and i just want to hear as many stories
as i can fit into these 20 minutes
lisandro take me back to your days of
journalism
who are you i studied economics
at the university of buenos aires in
argentina and
never expected to be a journalist but i
started as a journalist in economic
section of a major newspaper argentina
but i never wanted to be a journalist so
i made my degree at harvard
uh years afterwards as everybody does of
course
well it's a second-class diversity there
at the east coast of the united states
and i don't know about it
and i became unexpectedly when i was 32
years old
the secretary of state for foreign trade
for the nation and
this was absolutely unexpected for me
after graduating from harvard
and uh and during my fourth ten years
tenure at the government i reached the
conclusion that really the problem
that i was facing latin america was that
there was not investment capital
for pushing the talent of latin america
towards local markets
and this was venture capital so it would
be
explain to me so so dumb it down for me
you you're sitting there you're you're
working within the government you're
overlooking
you're overlooking what's happening and
what is this realization again you
realize that the innate problem
of the emerging markets is that they're
just not enough venture capital
i would say that for emerging markets
that want to expand themselves into
value-added products
into innovation there was no venture
capital
okay and and i thought that venture
capital was a crazy idea
because when i was the student at
harvard there was a guy there
that invented the to to do the
simulation of the cases
uh and so i plugged in his software
as a classmate of mine in my apple 2764k
this was in 1980 and this was the
invention of the electronic
uh spreadsheet it didn't exist the
electronic expression this was
invented as the under the name of the
calc yeah
after you you were not born no
afterwards
afterwards came uh multiplan
after king's lotus and lotus was
fantastic
because you put key in it
in your keyboard and transform
a a bunch of numbers into a graph
interactively and this was lotus and all
this is old story everybody now
is under excel but the concept of
electronic spreadsheet
was invented at a harvard business
school between a person that wanted to
save time
in preparing the cases and a guy from
mit
i crossed the river to the kennedy
school of government
and imagine what happened there was a
huge discussion there
just discussion was well listen this was
1980.
listen who owns the patent
and the discussion was the patent should
be on one third by the inventor
one-third by the laboratory of of the
harvard
university and one-third by the
university endowment as a whole
and when this was fixed how to split the
the ownership of the patent the guy
received millions of dollars to develop
a genome project so i thought this is
crazy
ideas that happen only in the states but
i came back to argentina latin america
and i realized that if latin america
wants to develop
entrepreneurial innovative projects in
technology
we should join the venture capital
world and so i started the venture
capital in 19
i would say 89 no lisandro
i just want to point out that you i mean
we almost just went
past it but you were sitting there
working you know meeting and discussing
entrepreneurship with the person that
invented you know the the technology
behind
the the first spreadsheets but but
you're getting this inspiration and
you're sitting in your understanding
like wow all this entrepreneurial spirit
here in cambridge
why don't we have this in latin america
you arrived there in 1989
what is the entrepreneurial scene over
there and what is the venture capital
scene
when you go back over there oh listen
venture capital didn't exist in latin
america at all
i wa one of the founders of endeavor
which is an ngo that promotes
entrepreneurship in latin america
is the equivalent of the kaufman
foundation and when this was invented i
reached
one guy this was in 1998
that was an entrepreneur wow and so the
guy
was iris i was receiving his office by
the assistant
and uh and the assistant said listen
there's here a guy on the name of peter
kenner and linda rottenberg from u.s
have come with lisandro brill
they want to do venture capital they are
here with a backpack they are very
picture people very nice but i i don't
know what what they do it seems
that adventure is something like
adventure
tourism in patagonia latin america
so people didn't understand a clue of
what venture capital was about
and uh and when i wanted to reach a
family
office this happened to me also in 19
in 1992 explaining what venture capital
that we have to do incubation
for startups after 20 minutes discussion
the guy that was
an older said listen i still do not
understand in this incubator what kind
of
chicken you are growing
so venture capital world did not exist
in latin america till i would say 1998
with all the blue of the internet
that was developed with e-commerce just
blew out
right and uh and so i was able to to
raise my
first fight my first one was he was
underwritten by higgs boson first out of
dallas texas they were in love with
argentina
they love buenos aires they love
entrepreneurial spirit they loved it
and say how is it possible we have to
bring educators there and this was the
very first
venture capital fan i would say in latin
america we invested 20 billion dollars
and one of the first companies we
invested is very well known by you
because it came out from stanford
university
founded by a guy on the name of marco
scalperin
who just did a copy of ebay amazon
and created mercado libre mercado leader
today
in latin america which is only six
percent or seven percent of latin
america is under e-commerce
but today is valued 49
billion dollars and it's just eating the
market of retail in the region
not only with e-commerce but also with
financial services
so this provides an example that
entrepreneurship can happen this part of
the world that
can develop if adequate funding is
available
especially if you have funds and and
receipts and gps general partners
that know how to to grow companies of
course and now you're actually
co-founder of you know the latin america
uh
segment of j ventures which we're both a
part of
correctly because my family came from
uh prosecuted from programs from from
ukraine
in 1905. so there is a jewish community
of 250 000 people is
third after us in america is that
following
community of jewish people i belong to
this community and i was very much
uh really uh motivated by the vision of
ordered hermony
laura ladder and jim koslan to connect
the diaspora of us people to
help develop our strength in our
community with a
with the activity of doing business
which is the same
thing that my father did in 1950s wow i
remember my father
when i he used to to go around the world
doing business in trade and i said
but you don't speak english and he said
well it is god did it because i do speak
english
do you hashtag english yes yes i do
so he he created businesses because
he networked with the jewish community
around the world is an old tradition of
our community yes
wow okay lisandro give me your insight
into the latin america
uh entrepreneurial and venture capital
scene today
you know coming in from from israel and
from the u.s
i don't get exposed too much to what's
happening in latin america
and you know the closest the closest
i've been there is is to go around and
meet
entrepreneurs and vcs in mexico to try
and get a little bit of the taste of
what are the challenges of emerging
markets because is it considered an
emerging market
a developing market that is still not
matured yet i'm assuming it is but i
just want to make sure
venture capital is embryonic in latin
america it's very easy
latin america is 600 million people
50 percent is brazil free but they don't
speak portuguese
50 is spanish-speaking latin america
and the most important countries are
brazilian portuguese
mexico argentina colombia and afterwards
the rest so venture capital is studying
latin america
uh by far the most important country is
brazil
we have minimum 30 funds in brazil
very much supported originally by the
government but also by the investors
from the silicon valley
you have cassette monashis red points
are the names of the games here in
mexico
i am a partner with alta alta ventures
and dallas capital
they are based there a veteran partner
in dallas and
is a smaller country but i would say
that brazil
and mexico are the two only countries in
latin america
that can develop the j curve of venture
capital that
means companies domestically that can
grow to the size
of being big plays so for example you
have
our most famous case may be new bank
that is 40 billion
market cup is a fintech company in
brazil
but you have dd which is the uber
originally
of brazil that was sold to dd
in china for a billion dollars and you
have in mexico companies such as clip
that is a square right in
the u.s but there are values well above
half a billion dollars today
and and and of course
this is a part of the story which is
deals basically with i.t
with software i am now pushing a lot
bringing insulin technologies and silica
valley technologies
invested by j ventures to latin america
in the agri-food tech space
you have a nice company there in uh in j
ventures based in mountain view
of palo alto on the name of big hero but
is trying to enter
but in america because they do
pollination
and they increase the productivity of
crops by 30 percent
incredible fighting how much
contribution you can make
to food security around the world and
saving these around the world yeah
of course of course of course and
argentina
and brazil are great places for for crop
production
we we can feed in the world minimum
2 billion people uh and we are only
let's say 200 million people 250 million
people inhabited so
we have the capacity because you have
the technology there
you have the artificial intelligence but
in order to embed
proteins into something that is called
food
you need land and water so far
and israel nor california have land
or water to feed and create these
proteins
this is being done here in south america
as a major destination so what do you
just i just want to clarify you just
said that
in that latin america there are places
that accumulate to about 200 million
citizens a population of 200 million but
the land
and the the potential is to grow food
that can fit
that can feed 2 billion yes i
uh yes because because argentina is a
country of 40 million people
and can has land and water with the
adequate technology to feed the billion
people
it sounds like it sounds like a gold
mine and it sounds like a it sounds like
these places have so much incredible
potential that why are people why are
entrepreneurs
you know wasting their time here in palo
alto you know building
in new new social apps for millions of
people if they can go to latin america
and work on problems that can feed
billions it sounds like it's
it's it's a much better idea to go to
latin america and
do technology there no well
uh is an untapped continent
so i would say that our role your role
matthias the role of j ventures
is exactly to connect these communities
with the
philosophy you know of chikuno land yes
no no of course
as always like to say other ceremonies
likes to say as laura lawder likes to
say
as ronald cohen likes to say that we
listened to him last
last week and uh and of course there is
a lot of opportunity
in as much as you partner with people
that know how to cope with our
characteristics
because you take a new york guy that
went to harvard or to stanford and
he lands in bercheva and he lands
in tel aviv i am sure that he will not
come with a shoot school spa
nature right have to adapt he will have
to partner
so so i would say that the secret
is to have a global thinking to capture
opportunity
and have take the knowledge and
experience to
to act locally to deliver globally
wonderful okay lisandra so you know i
came to stanford
from my military service a lot of my
friends went to go do startups and go
work
but i i felt that i didn't understand
what are the biggest problems that the
world needs to be solved and
and what are the biggest things in
tikkun alam that i can do
that are both profitable but also have a
great impact for
great net positive impact for the world
and you know so i'm taking up on this
offer i'm finishing here
about food it's about health
is about housing okay so alessandro the
deal is that i'm finishing up this
degree here
and then i'm coming to latin america i'm
taking you as a mentor and you're
telling and you're showing me
how i can use deep technology to solve
big problems
in your continent
amazing we we have this on record so
this is fantastic but i want to spend
the next five minutes or so
talking about your passions what what
are you truly excited about
as an investor as an entrepreneur as a
thinker as a tecuno lawmaker
my passion is human development and
progress
what does that mean uh um
human development and progress is to to
live in a world
where basic needs in terms of nutrition
1500 calories per person education
15 years of education guaranteed
uh health access to health as you have
in israel or as you have in kaiser
permanente
they are in in california and let's say
square meters per person for living once
you have
this you are assured that you have the
freedom to choose and become
a free person a citizen of the world
i love this and do you know who
invented this concept of developing
economics with this human development
approach
this was invented in silicon valley
by a guy who was a human psychologist on
the name of
maslow i was just about to say the
maslow pyramid which talks about this
idea that you need the foundations
before you can reach fulfillment
so connect my passion is to connect
venture capital
with the abraham muscle pyramid
to develop human needs to push for
human freedom on the global scales and
this is the
only in my judgment guarantee for
security
wow unbelievable so so does that guide
your
investment strategy and the types of
projects that you're working on
obviously
you're taking up your precious time and
you're working also with j ventures an
early stage fund
but but is this from a is this from a
mindset of
i'm going to take on projects that have
the potential to reach
meaningful net positive outcomes on
human lives i i'm always driven by
impact investing
okay uh during the 90s early the century
impact
investing the name of the game was
creating great
companies creating big companies uh and
creating endeavor
my ngo that we invented in argentina now
we are in 25 countries around the world
to promote economic development but
as of today i would say that creating
this wealth
has not been enough now we have applied
to this technology to which
called impact investing which is what we
have heard
at j ventures from ronald cohen yes
about the environmental sustainable that
have
inclusion potential to feed people to
nurture people
to provide for help and no doubt that
food tech and health tech will be major
areas of investment because family
offices
institutional investors are pushing
the the venture capital private equity
industry
to invest in things that make the world
more sustainable
100 lisandro that i mean that's just so
inspiring to hear
i before we leave and i can't believe 20
minutes are almost up we have just a
minute left but
i want to know your three words that you
would use to describe yourself and i'd
love an explanation about them because
i think that that your your mindset is
fascinating your ambitions are
are incredible and i i just love this
this notion of going through your
journey both as an entrepreneur venture
capital you know government worker
with the mindset of improving humanity
and freeing the people
from the shackles of of food of of water
of health of of living so
so please lisandro three words that best
describe you
a passion for human development to allow
for world security
hiku okay so the labs it's all
about that it's all about this
that impact right right
okay essentially one tip that you would
give
me or any other entrepreneur that's
starting their journey
you know impact investing and tikkun is
not necessarily in the mindset of every
young entrepreneur today
going into this world so what is one
thing that i should keep in mind
as i go through my path
travel know the world connect deeply
with the people around the world right
because you have
a fantastic background coming from
israel
you can connect your world the stanford
world
with these people and we are no we are
now
sure that we live in a global system
where everything is connected this is
the time
of the pandemics of kavit
that people realize that we are in one
world
and we have to connect to each other in
a positive sun game
a hundred percent a hundred percent
lisandro toda thank you so so much
thank you for the inspiration thank you
for everything you're doing and i'm
gonna see you in latin america when we
work together
come here more than welcome of course
take care sandra thank you very much
bye bye